what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start make sure you get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
they have shipped and a lot have been
delivered this week make sure you
tweeted me your selfie in your women
shouldn't vote T-shirt with the hashtag
IEM so I can either deem your outfit as
appropriate or inappropriate so today I
have a lot of stories to cover the first
story we had our number one Super Fan
Doug MPA send us this video Doug has
been a fan of ours since the very
beginning um I think he was the first
guy when I had like 15,000 subscribers
to say I know you're going to blow up so
thank you shout out to Doug for sending
me that um this is a video of an
overweight woman flexing her cooking
let's pull it up to and rice yes see
it come on man yeahall know I'm not
going to play in the
kitchen play by a lot of
things but in that kitchen ain't one of
them get into the
chicken
[Music]
yes
so
tender how you like it
baby
good look at that
onion
only women will glorify their bad
decisions online if a man is a drug
dealer he will at least come forward and
say don't do drugs guys but not only do
women glorify bad decisions they profit
off of it you know that the only reason
that this is going viral is because it's
an overweight woman eating a lot of food
what we are watching is actually suicide
that is slow suicide in front of our
eyes and being that morbidly obese is
selfish because the people in your life
are the ones that are going to have to
pay for your bad decisions they are the
ones that are going to have to take care
of you and what it does is if you have
children you have an early death if you
don't have children your parents or
maybe your friends maybe your other
family members are then going to have to
take care of you when you're in the
hospital you become a burden to
everybody around you and what I don't
understand is why we glorify this you
know there used to be a time where we
had shame in things where you didn't
want to glorify or show your s like you
used to be embarrassed and there's this
weird culture on Tik Tok where we want
to put on a pedestal being flawed and
showing what we do wrong in the name of
being relatable and I've seen this trend
even on Tik Tok with Housewives I I saw
an account that was I I'm a bad
housewife and I I don't really think
that we should be glorifying eating like
this and I know I know with the fat
acceptance people they'll say she's just
existing she's just existing in her body
well when you're
eating that much food and really your
portion sizes are going to put you in an
early grave can you blame the public for
being disgusted and watching that it
it's disgusting it is horrendous that we
live in a society where you can openly
commit suicide on these public platforms
by overeating what if we had people
doing heroin on public platforms forms
but because it's food it's somehow
acceptable I don't know anything about
you know this account P personally the
fat acceptance movement doesn't actually
want Solutions you know a couple months
back I actually applied for a body
positive social media internship
consistently I do respect your opinion
I'm I'm applying for the job you know
and you are applying for this position
with a misunderstanding of kind of what
our organization does that and so that
might make it difficult it it's really
difficult to consider you as an option
just because if not this is not our
perspective of body positivity and not
something that you're passionate about
no I'm very passionate about body
positivity the positive ways to lose
lose the flab we we do prioritize Health
but we just don't believe that weight is
you know one of the best indicators of
Health I mean guys who's more perfect I
mean I'm pretty good I'm pretty good at
the social media thing they said they
needed posts I had the kindness of my
heart I said I would step up to the
plate and do you know what happened you
know when I said to this organization
and this was like a young girl
interviewing me so it's not really her
fault but this organization whenever I
said hey let's be body positive and give
them the tools to lose weight their
response was that oh no we need to
accept them as they are why you know if
you are a drug addict do you just accept
that if you're homeless should you just
accept that no we should always be
trying to be better and improve and
overcome our demons but when you have a
whole industry that is making money off
of being fat why get thin why get thin
when you have the entire world telling
you to stay obese to stay overweight so
the comment section weighs in on this
the well-fed life says when your eyes
and mouth look like two dots you need to
slow down I know the likes have folks in
a headlock but y'all really are watching
someone un alive themselves SL slowly
exactly this is suicide being that
overweight is absolutely suicide cynical
queen says why do people always feel the
need to give this woman Health advice in
the comments you don't think she knows
this clearly she's here for a good time
not a long time and I do understand this
point of view you know I think from
their point of view they're not hurting
anybody but when you are going into the
Public Square and social media in 2023
this is the Public Square and you are
leading with your wait you are leading
with eating leading with eating you know
she could come on and talk about
anything else you know she could come on
and try to overcome her demons she could
come on and try to talk about history
she could talk about a completely
different topic but and again this is a
female thing where we put the negative
parts of us on a pedestal and make
videos and somehow make money off of
being relatable I don't it's not it's
not my thing the last comment says I
don't know how to feel about this she is
such a beautiful person inside and out
but the unhealthy obsession with food is
not good what you do now may not show up
for another 10 years but you will have
major problems be blessed and that is
the honest truth I appreciate this
commenter Lisa for being actually honest
with her because the consequences of her
decisions will catch up with her no
matter how much us women live in la la
land reality will hit us in the face at
some point just like reality is going to
hit the investment Market soon if you
are new to investing and have savings
that you need to protect right now with
the Middle East War the Ukraine war and
maybe Taiwan soon you need a new
playbook that is safe allocate some gold
now and avoid being in a frenzied Panic
of the unprepared when fear Reigns gold
protects the wise Noble gold Investments
offers a free 5 ounce America the
Beautiful coin with new IRAs this month
Shield your savings with a noble gold
Investments Ira go to Noble gold
investments.com now that's Noble gold
invest m.com now the only gold company
that I trust okay so a couple of days
ago Christine and I covered the story of
a woman doing a very weird
insemination
insemination um meeting matchmaking so
remember this this chick tweets she says
her friend Elizabeth is looking for an
unvaxxed sperm donor she lists her
requirements for a guy she posts some
pictures of herself and she says that
she wants a guy to make a baby with a
multiple babies and they don't actually
need to raise the kid she'll be a good
mom it was one of the weirdest things I
have seen in a long time long time so I
didn't think that anyone would be crazy
enough to take her up on this offer but
I guess the internet is a weird place
and they found a match let's pull it
up oh and I didn't think anybody would
really take her up on this
offer but I guess there have been tons
of men messaging
her um to inseminate
her King is that
you I'm just
kidding but I guess they met up and now
they've consummated you know we used to
do marriage but now we're doing
insemination so this is the lucky
guy this is the weirdest thing that I've
seen in a while I I I don't this is a
whole different level of women choosing
to be single mothers I can't decide if
this is weirder than IVF and I know I
know you what you guys are thinking okay
you're thinking pearl of course this is
weirder than IVF I mean is IVF weirder I
mean this is a natural way I guess like
IVF you don't even meet the guy and they
like do some like egg scraping I don't
really understand it it's not my thing
this is weird this is pretty up there
pretty Prett weird it it shows a trend
in the culture that women would rather
reproduce with a small percentage of men
that fit her requirements without a guy
there then reproduce with someone that
she deems as below her um Stella tweets
I would like to say thank you to all the
sperm donor candidate applications I'm
overwhelmed by the amount of support and
Lizzie is incredibly happy in fact we
have already found her a Suitor and he's
booked his flight to Vermont this is
Vermont
I thought this would not be an
America all right this app is truly a
godsend and if all goes to plan she may
be open to another Suitor in the near
future if reinsemination with her
current bull Isn't desired more of my
friends have expressed their interest in
natural insemination so we may have a
future and more post coming your way
stay tuned to all okay okay so now I
guess the I guess it happened or maybe
they I don't know um OMG the bull is
here Lizzy double ovulated this month
and Eric booked his flight on super
short notice to strike while the iron is
hot he fits the bill perfectly has great
genetics and is very excited for his
lucky day he will be a firsttime father
but between his librarian job and his
fur babies he does not have time to take
care of
it okay guys I have to be honest
when they when they said he didn't have
time to take care of it I thought I
really thought it would be a a more
demanding career now I'm not trying to
speak ill of librarian but that actually
sounds like a pretty familyfriendly
job I mean and I'm I'm wondering what
are they going to say to their children
so your father and I did this in
semination I don't even know how you
would explain this so they are truly a
match made in heaven with Lizzy's
consent I will be hopefully posting some
baby photos next year P.S any ladies who
are interested in natural insemination
please message me I've been doing
natural insemination matchmaking for
over two years but I've just now done it
with a public audience for the first
time I'm speechless
really oh my God this is so weird oh
this is so weird um she says Eric is a
little nervous but I've laid a coast bed
for them and fed him a big steak for
performance T minus one hour until they
be why do we have to be so public the
internet has just you know guys do you
know how many only fans boobs I have
seen this year from these these
tweeting at me their pictures you know
how many okay Stella it happened a a
heroic performance from Eric although
rather
speedy
he will be sticking around for after
care in two more rounds over the
upcoming days Lizzie feels like the
luckiest women alive getting is pure
Aryan
seed you know women used to say that I
feel like the luckiest woman alive
getting
married but I guess this is the new
thing their faces are so obviously AI
how do people not see this
I don't know these look real to me
guys I hope this is fake I really do
right such obvious they're not
even trying with the scops anymore what
if the hell is a
scop go the next one it's like it's like
to distract you right what's really
going on keep going um I don't know if
this is real or this is not real but you
know what I found with the Internet is
the things that you think are not real
like when I was in high school the idea
of an open relationship was just crazy
nobody would do that that's not real
that's just stuff on the internet but
crazy stuff on the internet becomes real
very fast I'll give you another example
when I was in high school trans people
in women's sports was unheard of that
will never happen that's just on the
internet now this last spring I saw a
bunch of dudes in my volleyball
tournament here in England so and
another I guess idea that seems unlikely
and fake and just out out there is
actually sex dolls so I would never
think in my right mind that any guy that
I know would ever want a sex doll that
any like what what guy would want a an
like a fake like an
artificial weird weird weird weird um
but I guess men want it so bad they're
they're really into these sex dolls
there's a man breaking into a store
going viral because he stole a sex doll
let's p it
up and they say chivalry is
dead and they say chivalry is dead and
so Andrew Tate commented on this he says
romantic relationships in 2023 baby
Diego weighs in and says this is what
women have men doing these days it is
sad discount Katie I'm just interested
to see what's going to happen when the
AI robot girlfriends come out it's just
going to get weird yeah like they
haven't even gotten out yet what is the
world going to be like with AI robot
girlfriends a scary place I don't even
like even this is making me feel weird
I'm like what the hell is that it show
it's kind of a sign of the times and I
was thinking about the history history
of gynocentrism because a lot of the
stuff that we say is like new really
isn't new it started a thousand years
ago this whole trend of putting women on
a pedestal women are so special and
amazing you know there's writings from
the 1800s about the men saying that
women's standards were too high so none
of this is new but what I will say is I
think every generation the women's
standards get higher and higher the
women's narcissism gets higher and
higher and higher and it's to the point
where there is going to be an entire
industry Outsourcing girlfriends and
wives and what would happen and
seriously guys what would happen if they
made artificial wounds you know and I
wonder if in the next 50 years there's
going to be more babies born in a test
tube than born in an actual womb and we
see a lot of these Trends not only take
place in society but also take place
really in in churches gynocentrism so
basically when women go into a field we
just tend to
really take away the competitiveness and
we tend to make everyone feel included
and put in all this woke stuff what I've
noticed right like you'll notice when
there's a campaign that goes viral for
the wrong reasons like the Bud Light
campaign it's a woman it's always a
woman behind it the BLM movement bunch
of lesbians are behind it um and what
you'll start to see now is church is a
business church is a business and they
need to make money and they need to fill
the pews and the way that they're doing
now is catering to women so now we have
a nonbinary priest in the Church of
England let's pull it up meet the Church
of England's first non-binary priest
36-year-old Bingo Allison is the first
openly non-binary priest to be ordained
in the Church of England Bingo grew up
in a strongly religious household where
being openly gay was considered a sinful
act the parent of three said it wasn't
until 7 years ago when they first came
across the term gender queer that
everything suddenly clicked if you don't
have the word for it then you can't
really own it for yourself but Bingo
claims that with the help of God they
eventually felt confident enough to come
out to the
world that is the most terrible thing
I've ever seen in my life I think it's
so disrespectful when we take religious
institutions that are supposed to be
guided by God and we put this woke
propaganda in it I cannot stand it
drives me nuts why are grown men that
know better co-signing on this that
priest was 70 80 years old you don't
think he knows that this is wrong and
it's sad because really we're starting
to see the churches cave into the woke
culture the churches are not supposed to
adapt to the culture and you know you
start to question is this end times and
and you start to question really why are
are men so desperate for women's approv
approval you know again these are
institutions that have been around for
hundreds of years and they are catering
to women why the top comment on this
video says Arsenal for life this is
disgusting what's happened to the world
Jordan halier says as an atheist gay man
I have to laugh my tits off at this when
you thought Colts couldn't get any more
ridiculous you know how crazy it is that
the gay guys are laughing at us and this
is the one thing about the left I don't
understand why they have feel the need
to mock religion you know there's
religions that I might not agree with I
might think they're incorrect but why
call it a cult why go out of your way to
mock the religion and what they are
doing in churches in 2023 is mocking
them TJ Johnson says I don't care how
woke the world gets the Bible is still
the Bible and it is definitely against
this yes yes there is no verse in the
Bible that says that we should be
supporting nonbi iary behavior in any
way and as the world goes crazy and
geopolitical tensions are escalating
inflation is Raging and despite what
they say stocks are sinking debt is
rising and your own financial future is
not looking too clever yet gold endures
every crisis war is disaster there is no
Calamity that has beaten gold while
paper assets crash and burn gold endures
every time you need to take a fresh look
at gold studying your portfolio right
now and get a free 5 ounce America the
Beautiful coin when you open up an IRA
with Noble gold Investments today Shield
your savings with Noble gold Investments
go to Noble gold investments.com now
that's Noble gold Investments the only
gold company that I trust so as you guys
know I have been following the story of
Adam 22 and his wife so for those of you
that don't know or maybe you're now just
tuning in Adam 22 went viral this summer
for essentially loaning out his wife to
another man Adam and his wife Lena the
plug got married in July then after that
they decid Ed they were going to shoot
their first corn scene with another guy
so essentially Adam wasn't there and
Lena and this guy Jason love did the
deed and then it went viral everybody on
the internet was commenting about it and
it was interesting because Adam 22 goes
after me he says Pearl is such a
misogynist after we had a nice interview
after we had a nice interview
um so I thought to myself what who's the
real misogynist you're the one loaning
out your wife and really I've even you
know I actually met um Sky Bri when I
was in LA for my interview with him and
the funny thing was she was all oh I
love I love corn all that stuff now now
she's saying she had to quit because she
had a boyfriend so really if we're going
to go off of misogyny points I say he's
the real misogynist he's the one that
doesn't like women I'm at least at least
being honest so anyways now I have to I
have to give credit where credits do
this is very creative I don't think I've
ever seen this before Adam is now making
a reality show to see who gets to do the
with his wife let's pull it up I'm Lena
the plug I am an adult Creator my name
is Adam 22 and I co-own plug talk with
my lovely wife we interview a different
girl every week and then we them at the
end
but we've only ever done it with other
women so we've arranged this whole
challenge to find the perfect guy to be
our first ever boy boy girl through
cheers Lena I came ready to you want to
do a dance off oh yeah I would love to
see a dance
off you tell me this guy that's porn let
me get in the room
with you want to get out no no get out
we going to get you out of the situation
big a soul hold on to get this improved
on
YouTube I really have no words I really
I I
really okay I've I've made my points on
this before so I'll just say it again
that is selfish it is selfish to trade
family values for money it is selfish to
think that there is a cost that
is worth putting inappropriate internet
behavior that your children will see on
YouTube he has a daughter and what is he
teaching his daughter that this type of
stuff is okay there is a comment Adam 22
comments who will be the next man to
bang my wife we created a new reality
show to find out dropping next
week Navy says I don't even see them as
a couple anymore just business people
with a kid so sad to see what money can
do my biggest point is why get
married why must you disrespect the
sanctity of marriage they didn't do any
of this until they got married it it
really is an insult to the people that
take marriage seriously and it degrades
the institution in itself this is why I
say that really marriage should just be
reserved for religious people and all of
this polymer open should just be in
long-term relationships I don't see the
point of getting married if you're GNA
do this crazy stuff pereles Perry says
I'd bang a thousand men before I let
another man bang my
woman you might be a little gay I won't
lie to you I'm sorry I don't know about
that I don't know what what you pick but
that that might be I I appreciate the
sentiment okay IQ cev your kids will see
all of this yes that was my point you
know people do what they're going to do
make your money whatever but why do
things that will embarrass your family
and in the times of the past you knew
that you were not meant to embarrass
your family so there was things that you
did not do or you were at least socially
shamed but now people make a bag off of
this and really it shows the problem
when you put money above family in
society so last story of the day I went
on GB news this morning and I really I
had to talk about about a really serious
topic to be honest you know in in
society I really I'm just
depressed I I did sports for 16
years I think even longer now that I
think about it and they never they
never I never made a bag off of sports
I've played so much just for free it's
just been
terrible and so they invited me on to
talk about my oppression let's pull it
up challenges when it comes to managing
a men's team to a women's team yes
you're going to have the you know that
the men want to make a name for
themselves individually as well as a
team so you have got to manage those you
know those different attitudes in a team
but there isn't any reason that people
like Serena vman or Emma Hayes or other
women managers there's no reason they
can't do that well I just think if women
were so good at managing a team they
would be better at managing their league
I mean women by and large women's
leagues are not profitable women's
leagues do not make money so how are we
going to say we are so great and amazing
and awesome at managing a team when we
can't even manage our own League the
majority of women's leagues really are
subsidized by the
men I think the WSL is creating so much
revenue at the minute and even women's
football in America is you know really
equal to the men's game as well I think
it's not equal at all if you look at
profits it's not even close it's not
equal but in terms of the people that
are watching the game and you know
spending money on the game you know it's
making so much money to what it was you
know even five years ago and I don't see
there's any issue compared to yeah if
it's unprofitable and that's again which
goes back to the problem women's sports
don't tend to make money um if they do
tend to make money it tends to be their
monetizing sexuality in some way but
really by and large women's sports do
not make money and I've really seen this
become a political issue over the years
where the women will cry and whine and
and moan about their
when really um by and large women do not
deserve more money because they do not
make what the men make and it becomes a
political issue where we want more money
for Less work and I can't stand it I'm a
female athlete I've been in athletics
for 16 years and I'm really sick of it
becoming a handout off who can get the
most handouts really I think if women
want more money and they want to be in
these positions we wouldn't have to keep
saying we need females in these
positions they would just be in those
positions we need competent people
there's a shortage of competent people
in the world if you are competent you
will get the role and women want special
handouts and treatment and we're even
doing a whole segment on female managers
what does that tell us that we're not
competent enough in general to get the
roles I think obviously we know that the
men's game in football and in other
sports do produce more Revenue but that
doesn't mean the women's game doesn't
produce Revenue you just look at the WSL
in England and the men's grounds are
being used to house the women's games
now and they're selling out those
grounds and that's just showing how far
the game is coming and I think you know
it is a matter of time before someone
breaks that barrier and will manage a
men's team high up by by and large
women's sports operate at a loss the
WNBA operates at a loss um College
athletics Women's College athletics it's
subsidized by male Athletics by and
large women's sports operates at a loss
just cuz maybe you could point to one
small League somewhere or one League
which really by and large I don't know
five female footballers uh most people
couldn't list you five female
footballers and the only ones you can
really list are the ones that have
become political they make it a
political movement and I think it ruins
the sanctity of the sport because we're
more worried about getting a female
manager than we are in improving the
game yeah isn't but Pearl it isn't part
of the issue here you say it's you the
women can't manage it it's you know it's
not as profitable as it could be and all
the rest of it but that's that's not
down to the game it's not down to the
players or the managers that's down to
the public not supporting it in the same
way and that is something certainly in
the UK that we are seeing start to
change the public doesn't support it
because it's not as entertaining I mean
do you do you sir can you list 10 female
soccer players well no but I exactly
that's my point support us support us
please I I couldn't I that's my point
that's my point because it's not
entertaining that's a m a mute point
because I could I could named 10 male
players so and here here's the thing I
don't even I don't even watch socer but
you know really by and large I I could
tell you more male players than female
players because the males are more
entertaining and my thing is ladies
ladies ladies ladies if you want people
to watch be more entertaining and then
you will get more viewers stop shaming
the viewers if a product is not selling
you don't go to the market and say you
bad customers you're just not supporting
my product you improve the product so I
say improve the level of the game be
more entertaining and then people will
watch if you're not willing to do that
stop crying to me about it Megan last
word from
you I mean you obviously don't sort of
pay attention to the WSL in England
because that's got its own fan base in
itself and I if I ask those people they
invest their time in the women's game if
they can name five players they can
probably name 50 women's players in the
game because they invest their time in
it let's go on the streets of England
and tell them name five female soccer
players and name five male soccer
players well I tell you what you've both
been very entertaining just on this
subject so but we've got to wind you up
there but thanks very very much indeed I
will should I do that interview you guys
want me to do that street interview on
the streets of England and I ask name
five male soccer players name five
female soccer players I could do it I
was so excited to go and talk about this
I played Sports since I was in maybe
fifth grade and I think I started
basketball even earlier I I don't even
remember when I started my entire life
Athletics volleyball basketball track um
I even played lacrosse for a little bit
Athletics has always been a part of my
life and I could tell you some really
awesome things that I got from Athletics
I learned to work hard I learned to go
after my goals I learned that life isn't
always fair and sometimes the coach
doesn't like you sometimes you don't get
your way but you have to deal with it
and figure out a way to make it work I
learned how to get along with people I
learned how to work in a team there were
so many positive things that I got in
female sports but that does not negate
from the fact that it is not profitable
and really women's Athletics should be
thankful to men that they allow us to
play most of our leagues would not exist
if we were not subsidized by the men
I'll give you an example in the same
breath where that woman was talking
about how much money the women were
making she also was saying that they
were selling out the men's Stadium you
we get to use their equipment for free
that they paid for typically a lot of
the systems and processes that they use
to Market these games which still
operate at a loss for the most part most
women's leagues operate at a loss um
were developed by The Men We are so
lucky to have male athletes allow us to
play and as a thank you all they do is
whine and complain and make it a
political movement I am so tired of
hearing about the politics of these
women's soccer players and it it
distracts from the actual game the the
short-haired chick like on the soccer
team I forget her name going around
complaining about the pay everywhere I
know I don't even know what she is like
on the field because women lead with
their complaints instead of leading
meeting with their talent if I was going
to make women's sports profitable I
think there's two ways you could do it
I'm an ideas gal look at look how nice
to me this is I'm literally telling I'm
telling everybody I think you could do
it by having influencers play sports or
monetizing the women's social media I
think that's one way you could do it the
other one I I can't I it's it's through
sexuality which I'm not I'm not really
for or really by making it a charity and
getting sponsors to donate yeah my
producer King is saying playing bikinis
I'm not I mean why do you think women's
beach volleyball makes
money you know and the funny thing is
women don't pick women bosses women
don't go watch women's games women don't
even support the things that they say
they care about and so what these
commentator does is he's virtue
signaling he's saying well and you know
I think it's part of his job but he's
still saying well Pearl but the public
shouldn't the public support supp this
well not if it's not entertaining that's
what I want to say to female athletes
out there maybe we could come together
and brainstorm ways to get the viewers
watching but instead we brainstorm about
how we can rob the men more because when
you're asking for a pay raise without
producing revenue and profit then really
you're just asking for a handout and the
thing that I love about sports is it
teaches you not to ask for handouts it
teaches you to get better at things it
teaches you to work hard and it's gone
from something where really it was a net
positive we would all work hard to get
to a certain point and we wouldn't make
excuses and cry and complain to now it's
just a whine off a handout off and I am
tired of seeing it so as you guys know
at the end of every show we always take
the top comment from the last video so
the last video's top comment was from
freed Finance if you are valued for your
looks alone what do you have when you're
old and I think that is great point
because if you don't put any emphasis on
your character then you will have
nothing let me know what you guys think
in the comments like your favorite
comment below and I will talk to you
guys next time